How are you guys doing? Mubarak to you.
And before we start, I should say that
we're raising money for the people of
Lebanon. Uh the people have been
devastated by the strikes by the Zionist
entity. Uh Muslims, Christians, Sunni,
Shia, it doesn't matter. We're raising
money for the poor people of this
country of Lebanon which is accessible.
We have Mercy to Humanity which do
excellent work on the ground. Click the
link below. We're trying to get up to
50,000. We're on 40. Let's try and meet
that target in these blessed days. Nick
Fuentes is a Mexican-American individual
who's a racist and who I've spoken about
many times before. I had a conversation
with Sneo in the flesh uh about him and
I mentioned to him many times that this
is a person not to be trusted and this
individual has come out and proved me
correct because he's essentially
advocated some kind of I would say
an underhanded way some sort of passive
aggressive violence but he's a proxy man
he's a weak and cowardly individual so
he couldn't uh do it properly. Let's
take a look at the clip and respond to
it in kind. You don't want me as a
friend. Let's see how you like the
Gropers as enemies then. And if you see
Sneo in New York, I want you to tell
them on my be on my behalf. Tell them
youing
brown clown. It's over. Forget it.
That's insane. I think I was nothing but
nice. So, I was wondering what exactly
is he so angry with Sneo about
considering the fact that Sneo has been,
you know, helping him out and
platforming him on the different
platforms and stuff like Fresh and Fit
and Andrew Tate, I think, is the one who
>> and he's very placid and domesticated
when he's sitting next to Sneo. He is
>> and here he seems quite irritated. So,
we're trying to see what's the switch.
>> So, I wanted to see exactly what it is.
So I came across this particular video
which is a very short video where Sneo
is talking about who can I unite the
right wing and the left wing against the
Israeli calls. Let's take a look at the
video.
>> Is there anybody else who should be on
this like anti- you know Israel critical
streamers? So who has the most potential
to do it? Let's analyze this no bias.
Nick, there was many opportunities for
him to try to unify the left and the
right post Charlie Kirk and that
rhetoric and you saw even what he
tweeted today. He keeps talking a lot
about left right. I don't think he is.
I don't think the left likes him at all.
I mean, he he's clearly been against
them. I I I see this is about maybe 10%
chance that he can even get the left.
>> So, there's nothing really much to it
there.
>> I think he's being respectful, to be
honest. The way he spoke about him, I I
don't think anything was outlandish. And
the reaction is asymmetrical to what
he's reacting to.
He's watching his content like a good
school boy and he's reacting to it as if
his value is judged according to what is
uttered by sneakers.
>> Well, Nick Fuentes is an individual
who's got one thing that he does
consistently. He's very very strong.
He's very powerful when he's in his
mom's basement. Okay. Or his father's
Mexican father's basement. Okay. Maybe
he put the piñata. He put this on that
and he had the tortilla and he's
celebrating Mexico and he should have a
Mexican flag behind him. and his father,
the immigrant Mexican, all of that. He's
a very he's a lion when he's in his
little room, but when he's in social
settings, when he's actually in in in
the public, you see him cowering every
single time. His body language doesn't
like
>> he's like sitting and he's Yeah,
>> his physiology, his physioamy,
everything about him screams a poxy
small coward insecure.
>> And then he's saying he's he's trying to
incite his incel followers. He's saying
it's on site. On site, what what have
you what have you been able to achieve
physically? So, you're going to find a
bunch of people with social anxiety to
try and take on a streamer. And we know
in the past that Sneo is actually
physically attacked. Yes. When he's out
there. So, we can see this this face
mask slipping. He's obviously inciting
his followers. But what are they going
to do at the end of the day?
>> And the fact is this, and this is a
lesson to a lot of our Muslim brothers
out there, especially in the da. Allah
says in the Quran
that the Jews and Christians will never
truly be pleased with you until you
follow their way. This individual in
particular, he's not just a normal Jew
or normal Christian because the Quran
also says the Jews and Christians are
not all the same. They're not all to be
painted with the same brush. Yeah. You
know and in fact some of them are so
close to you and some of them are you'll
find that
the ones who are closest to you are the
ones who say we are Christians. So we're
not generalizing the Christians but what
we are saying is when you have a race
realist a racist somebody who's far
right
with identity issues.
>> It doesn't matter now if you're in this
case anti-Israel. I wouldn't even call
him pro Palestine. With all due respect
he's anti-Israel. Okay. Yes, he might
have been talking about the genocide in
a positive way and we won't take that
away from him. But the fact is when you
have those traits, when you're a race
realist, you're a racist, you're a far
right and you you've spoken derogatorily
and poratively about Muslims and all
these kind of things. We can't actually
I'm sorry to say about Islam and
Muslims. We can't unite with you and we
don't want to unite with you and we're
not interested in uniting with you and
we don't need to unite with you and
there's nothing that we need to unite
with you for and we don't need you and
your groer incel followers
>> cowardly people.
>> We don't need that. There's actually we
have no need liability to us.
>> We have no need for you. It's like it's
like having someone on your team who's
going to be failing and actually
bringing in attacks from other angles
because if if you actually look at this
particular creature,
>> what is he bringing to the table? I want
to know if there's a bunch of people.
Okay, we spoke about Dan. We spoke about
all these different people. They're
bringing something. What is he bringing?
>> He's bringing absolutely nothing to the
table. And I believe he it could be said
that he's been affected by the lobby.
The lobby might have given him a couple
of pennies of shekels here and there
because his whole tone changed. We've
seen how his own to his whole tone
changed now. He's softening his stance.
Maybe he's been told to cut ties with
this person, cut ties with that person.
You never know with these individual
>> maybe just be a fifth column. We don't
know.
>> We don't know about this guys. So here's
the fact and this is the what we need to
understand. We will never get as Muslims
until we become self-sufficient.
>> Yeah. The prophet Muhammad wasallam told
us
whoever is self-sufficient who seeks
self-sufficiency Allah gives him more
self-sufficiency.
Whenever Allah whenever somebody seeks
completion within themselves Allah gives
them more completion. So in other words,
we don't really like with all due
respect, we don't need to compromise our
positions and we don't need to bend our
knee in order to to uni unite with this
group or that group. If people want to
talk about Palestine, they're very
welcome. If they want to talk about the
genocide, they're very welcome. But
you're not going to humiliate
individuals. You're not going to come
and talk we're going to set people on
you. This and that and it's on site.
What are you talking about? It's on
site. What are you talking about? You're
a proxy man. That's not a threat
conversationally or physically. Yeah.
You are a Mexican man who's who's who's
posing as a white uh Caucasian American.
You are a racist guy and we haven't
forgotten about your race realist
arguments and your racist arguments
>> which are not only
>> and by the way you're not proven in any
field. You're not an academic. You're
not qualified in any field. Yeah. You're
not you've never debated anyone of
stock. Frankly, you've never fought
anyone physically. Just because you're
in the backyard and you got a couple
incelss here and there h ticking boxes
for you or commenting on your behalf.
Now you become emboldened to start
speaking as if you're a military leader.
Yeah. This and that and anyone on my
behalf and you're like a military
leader. You're a little proxy man.
You're not capable of being a military
leader or even a leader for your own
little family. So don't speak like this.
Yeah. And this is this is the fact.
These individuals, they're speaking like
really rough and tough.
>> There's a mismatch. There's a mismatch
between the way that you're coming
across and the words that are coming out
of your mouth. And for anyone to take
you seriously, at least have a way about
yourself and have some self-awareness.
This is how I come across. If I was to
watch a video like this, would you watch
a video like this and tremble?
>> Would you honestly think, "Oh my god, oh
my god."
>> Yeah. Good. You should know about your
limitations. You're not about that life.
You're not really about that. If you get
backhanded, and I said this to Sneo, I
said, "This is a guy and I swear by
Allah." And people were saying this and
that. I stand by it. If I backhand you,
okay, if I if you're standing in front
of my backhand, you're not you're not
even trying to defend yourself. You're
not a guy to speak tough. You're not a
guy to speak in this manner. So, here's
the fact. We Muslims don't need anybody
else. We need ourselves. We need to
unite within ourselves. Anyone who wants
to join our causes is more than welcome
to join. But when they come and try and
attack us like this and attack our
people like this and attack our brethren
and our comrades like this, no, we don't
accept it, bro.
>> Absolutely.
>> We don't accept it, bro. And you guys
are going to fizzle out because at the
end of the day, your cause is an
evacuous cause. Your right-wing racist
cause is weak. What we believe in is
strong, bro. What we believe in is the
purpose of life, that the creator of the
universe. We believe in an Islamic
cause. It's much stronger. And that's
why it's been resilient for all these
years.
>> Yeah. So at the end of the day, this is
the message to the Muslims. We need to
unite within ourselves and don't over
rely and this is even to Sneo. Don't
over rely on these individuals, you
know, like the Nick Fuentes, whether
it's leftwing or right-wing. Don't over
We can have a cordial but distant
relationship with individuals who hold
views like this because at the end of
the day, they're ticking time bombs. And
I myself should be saying this, you
know, about myself. I had my own
communications with Jordan Peterson
before he defected and became what he is
now.
>> That's a good example.
>> Yeah. I didn't know what he was going to
be. We all don't know. It's it's
hindsight. It's 2020. We all don't know.
But so long as we we keep a healthy
distance and when they do defect, we
say, "Well, we're just having a
conversation with this person who's got
and we we we're not connected to these
people." But when we try and defend
them, like Sneaker was defending this
guy for years, he was actually actively
defending him. We don't need to do that
with anyone outside of our community.
That's the fact and this is this is what
I'm saying. We we only need to defend
ourselves. We can of course defend
injustice. If injustice is done to
anybody,
if you speak, speak the truth. Even if
it's to someone that's close to you,
that be upright standing with justice,
even if it's against yourself or your
parents, even the Quran always talks
about justice. But when it comes to we
don't we're not in need. We're not in
need of the right or the left. We need
to find our own independence and
self-sufficiency. And with that, we
conclude. We don't accept uh Nick
Fuentes and this and that, these these
threat, veiled threats and stuff like
that. Don't try it because, you know, if
you got backhanded, you wouldn't
respond. You're nothing. You're a proxy
Mexican guy posing as a racist white man
and these incelss are following you
because they consider you to be some
guy, but you're not a guy that's
established in academia or in any
physical field at all. So, don't speak
like you are. you're nothing. And that's
all I have to say.